oh I'm so I'm so shameful
oh this is more powerful
I can feel the pride
[Music]
so we have
um an article here submitted by one of
our lovely patrons submitted by shoot
with a period after what's up shoot
there's not there's not much to say
about this one we're just gonna watch a
video okay all right here we go can
everybody see what
oh why did you minimize that looks like
some kind of suck machine you see a
doorbell suck machine there it is this
automated Spirit machine helps donors
wow to masturbate in hospitals
what's this less embarrassing Technology
Center yo I'd be at the hospital all the
time to help male patients extract sperm
for donation and medical analysis yeah I
would rather [__]
in terms of temperature wetness and
amount oh my goodness easy as men still
get paid to donate sperm and they just
get this [__] for free they have to make
a whole machine they just get to
basically [__] and get paid for it men
are basically prostitutes legal
prostitutes I didn't know that is it
height adjustable though paid for sperm
that's what I'm worried about yeah sperm
donors wow I thought that was for free
because it's like a donation no no can
you go to Salvation Army visit oh
because of the word donor yeah yeah wait
what's the price that you get paid
though how much is it do we versus at
least a few hundred I think for real
that's great that's the value though
girls get like thousands for their eggs
yeah but they all they but they have to
go through a lot more you have to uh be
put on hormones and like the hormones
make you crazy to then extract a healthy
egg yeah you don't have sex to have and
also you can't be on drugs you can't
drink you can't have any health issues
so me I'm like I've celiacs I'm already
cut out you have to have being like
perfect men no one [__] cares I'm
allergic to gluten
a real gluten allergy like a true
gluten-free diet she has to so this says
on a sperm donor uh pay FAQ that on
average sperm donors are paid between
100 to 150 per donation visit uh they're
encouraged uh on average shoe if you're
a sperm donor you've done it at least
once a week but they're encouraged to do
so too once a week do they use that much
[__] yeah is it like do they well you
probably gotta be like a athlete or
something they're not trying to get
donations from neckbeards and [__] I'm
pretty sure a bunch of athletes ain't
walking in no no I don't think the
athletes are embarrassed either but if I
can get you I'm so embarrassed can I
[__] the machine instead he's a [__]
yelping yeah because it's a Chinese cup
it's in China oh I'm so I'm so shameful
oh this is more platform
I could feel the pride
well that was my computer thank you
that's so weird I feel comfortable
I don't want to do it but it's for China
if you bring in athlete's sperm you get
more money athlete's sperm well you
could probably get paid like you know
how like this sperm goes for like like
if you're like a thoroughbred racehorse
and you're like a champion like ten
thousand dollars for sperm easily like
if you're an athlete but here's the
thing would you really want to get paid
to donate your sperm if girls are gonna
use it to get child support not for me
from others they can get child support
well I I don't I don't know like they
would have to have forms written out
that's like the most direct racket
though is that like the most uh dude
amount of sperm usage this is what we do
boys we gotta figure out where the
Lakers are or stand right you just suck
them off no we don't suck them off dude
okay we find their their condoms dude we
[__] cut them open we break we we
keep them in a little like uh you want a
black market athlete service
doesn't it need to be warm not cold I
don't know how works yeah and then
finally we have to arrange it in a
trench coat go to the bank and go hey
you guys want something and under the
Transco we're not wearing any clothes
you want some Century cabalos we can
have all the kind of donations all the
condoms and all their jersey numbers on
everything
do you guys remember was it Drake who
put Tabasco in his condom after he was
done yeah yeah he did he did do that
yeah Tabasco could do and then she tried
to like sue him or something but like
why are you trying to get his sperm out
of the trash can we can't just put
Tabasco in the condom that's not right
oh sure he puts it as a spermiston I
would kill this Fern yeah but that's not
fair to her she's trying to get his coat
dude it doesn't just make his babies
have a higher spice
that's weird
oh hold on
[Laughter]
it's pretty crazy protection for Drake
to be like I'm gonna need to do this
just in case and it worked out yeah they
have different problems though yeah I
wasn't famous enough to work why
wouldn't he just kind of upset to me at
that point that's my question he already
has a kid how many more do you need well
ask Nick Cannon because he needs more he
needs Tabasco that's true yeah
Nick Cannon should just donate sperm
with these machines yeah Nick Cannon is
like the modern Genghis Khan
everyone's gonna be part Nick Cannon in
the future
he is beautiful like you guys try it if
you had this video oh a thousand percent
that thing looks way better than what do
you I think we actually did thousand
percent an article like this you know
what there's another one too that's been
going around it's a smaller one and
people are using little bananas as an
example on it and the banana looks like
it's having a good time so you put the
banana
wait does the banana go in you well with
a
a new huge thing and like people like
those [__] machines so while they have
the VR porn it's just like a whole
cinematic experience they're never gonna
leave the house why would you leave the
house yeah so my friend Ryan pow now he
has pillow talk he's like I at least an
hour a day of er porn an hour yeah
that's how good machine too I don't know
about the [__] machine but I know he
watches an hour of VR he's like it
changed my life I mean here's if I'm
masturbating I'm doing it for at least
two hours and two hours two hours I I
like to come a lot and like my assistant
is like Adelia like didn't you I'm like
yes I'm coming like seven times did you
try to break records no is there a
number that you're like I'm gonna hit
eight today no
[Laughter]
can you just use a tripod yeah so that's
not even for Content just for you no
that's just that's just for me self-love
let's go find content and like you're
supposed to be putting on a performance
but if I'm just masturbating I want to
like lay back I want my stomach rolls
out and I just want to be like enjoying
myself right watching TV yeah fun fact I
like to masturbate to like movies or
like TV shows that I'm like that's
[__] hot what show yeah yeah what's
the job the office Wolf of Wall Street
Wall Street coming out in that scene uh
the one where she's got her legs open on
the floor yeah no no not that one that's
that's when she first comes out yeah
when she's at the party yeah I know
naked naked the orgy scene no
[Applause]
not the not the candle wax on the on his
butt not Jonah Hill's child do you know
that one was [__] funny I love Jonah
Hill so much yeah one of the rocky was
hot and wolfen walls yeah that was yeah
that was like a breakout hotness like
overload oh for sure yeah it was like a
Megan Fox and Transformers moment I
heard that orgy scene smelled really bad
really it's yours what the janitor told
you go out on a plane the The Wolf of
Wall Street window but on the plane I
think I forgot
yeah it would be the plain one it was I
don't know they had one right
I was high when I what's the TV show
that you masturbate to the last of us
and why is it night rider Knight Rider I
feel bad about
just watched her uh like documentary
like Pam talked about Baywatch oh no ham
and Tommy yeah and then she looks like
really bad for masturbating to it but I
don't think she'd find that if you know
anybody a lot of people masturbated to
the original anyways the boat when
they're when they're [__] on the boat
see I didn't do it to that I didn't
this is my public apology I am so sorry
Pam I thought you had your had been sent
and Tommy was on Ward my bad dude the
story the real story is sad yeah like it
did not do her any good so flick it
flick into it it's the the news stories
that's out she's super cool yeah dude
her personality
the thing because like when I read I
read I didn't like see the stuff about
Pam Anderson saying like I didn't give
consent I saw the part where like Tommy
was like it was based off my book and he
was involved so I'm like if Tommy was
involved Pam is probably like you know
yeah it's to be assumed yeah that
weren't accurate so I don't I don't do
it anymore but I was
so my bad I'm still a feminist you know
what I'm not a bad person I think she
gave you a pass bro I also apologize for
my teen self uh I thought that that
distribution of material was just free
for everybody yeah it was one of the
first shows that gave me a boner
see that's kind of romantic you know
what I mean the slow balls that video
hey
I remember me and all my friends
watching TV like when it was like a big
box shaped tee with the glass curved
screen yeah and then like we're like oh
my dick's so hard is yours are hard all
of us are so hard for watching Baywatch
like let's go pee in the toilet roll did
you guys sword Wyatt yeah we're just
peeing all over the toilet because
everyone's dick so hard
because you can't peep down everyone
just [__] pissing everyone's bent
over what the [__]
[Music]
all right